ah
[Música]
a
escala en parís
aída palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y de france
24 estamos a pocos días de la primera
vuelta de las elecciones presidenciales
francesas con unas encuestas que
vaticinan igual que en 2017 un duelo
entre el presidente saliente liberal
emanuel manjón y la ultraderechista
marine lepén con un cambio esta vez el
resultado podría ser mucho más estrecho
para analizar este ascenso de la extrema
derecha hoy hace escala en parís el
sociólogo arsenio o cuenca bienvenido al
señor con todo muchas gracias bueno este
test sociólogo estudia los extremismos
en internet y está haciendo un doctorado
en el crs de parís el centro nacional de
investigaciones científicas en estas
elecciones hay dos candidatos de extrema
derecha según las encuestas ma jing le
pen tiene alrededor del 22 por ciento de
las intenciones de voto y el otro
candidato de la extrema derecha dice
moore aunque se está desinflando no
desde hace unas semanas tiene alrededor
de un 10% de la intención de voto entre
los 2 totalizarían
hay 2 33% de las intenciones de voto
podemos decir que un tercio de los
franceses es de extrema derecha que la
sociedad sea ultra derechizado bueno
sería tentador pero al contrario de lo
que muchas encuestas de opinión parecen
mostrar realmente esto es solo
electorado que el día de las elecciones
se presenta en el colegio y vota ni
siquiera cuenta con las las personas que
se abstienen entonces sí que es cierto
que el espectro político francés se ha
derechizado incluso ultraderechista do
pero esto no corresponde con la sociedad
francesa que es mucho más compleja y
dejando aparte esos porcentajes como se
explica que se halla ultraderechista do
o derechizado en la sociedad francesa
bueno realmente en el momento en el que
los temas que normalmente
capitaliza la extrema derecha se
convierten en temas mediáticos empiezan
a permear en el mainstream
estos discursos al final se banalizan y
contribuye a que efectivamente estas
formaciones
ganen más peso a nivel electoral en el
momento además en el que no sólo estas
formaciones sino otras del arco
parlamentario empiezan a tratar estos
temas
inevitablemente pues normalmente se va a
salvar uno a la fuente original que es
la de estos partidos la sustitución por
ejemplo de la que habla de
la construcción de la sociedad francesa
por gente que viene del norte de áfrica
y es una expresión que utilizó de
valérie pécresse que es la candidatura
conservadora y qué perfil tienen los
votantes de extrema derecha en este 2022
normalmente se hace una distinción
en clave geográfica que para mí es muy
interesante según la cual en el norte
podemos ver un voto de clases populares
de extracción social baja que
normalmente tiene que ver con una
reivindicación anti establishment de
empleados obreros incluso de parados
en esta región
uno de los principales en clave es el no
es patria mientras que en el sur en la
región de pacquiao
encontramos un voto a lo mejor más
identitario de una clase social
más s como se dice aquí en francia mejor
establecida
y que tienen mucho más que ver con
temáticas relacionadas con la
inmigración con la seguridad con el
islam
igualmente el votante de extrema derecha
es complejo y está esta división entre
la candidatura del epen y des muy
muestra de ello
justamente el epen tendría igual habría
recuperado y esto desde hace mucho
tiempo un voto del partido comunista
según algunos estudios en la izquierda
en qué medida es responsable de que la
clase obrera se haya ido un poco hacia
la extrema derecha es cierto que las
formaciones de izquierdas que
históricamente han representado a la
clase trabajadora ya no
presentan candidatos
que se asimilen a los trabajadores que
supuestamente
parecen defender
igualmente en los últimos años las
formaciones de
izquierdas
socialdemócratas y populistas no han
apostado precisamente por las fórmulas
que siempre les han dado buenos
resultados como es la formación de
cuadros en el seno de sus partidos crear
estructuras fuertes de militancia y yo
pienso que esto les ha recortado en voto
vamos ahora entrar de lleno un poco en
su campo de estudio que es internet en
qué medida internet y las redes sociales
han influido en esta ultraderecha ción
de la sociedad es de qué forma ese
vehículo
las redes sociales estos debates de
ultraderecha
la ventaja y el inconveniente de las
redes sociales es que dan la palabra a
todo el mundo y cualquier mensaje puede
visualizarse sin pasar por una
estructura intermediaria como es ésta en
la que estamos usted y yo que son los
medios de comunicación
el frente nacional por ejemplo fue el
primer partido en crear una página web y
ofrecer su programa a los internautas
sea que este tipo de formaciones que
siempre han renegado de los medios de
comunicación y del establishment
político por solar los si bien esto es
bastante cuestionable yo creo que es una
postura victimista porque realmente sí
que les ha beneficiado esta exposición
en medios aunque haya sido más crítica
que la de otras formaciones pero claro
finalmente las redes sociales uno puede
liberar la palabra radical extremista y
reaccionaria sin muchos y mucho
inconveniente en comparación a la de los
medios y estaba calando no entre los
internautas por supuesto por supuesto
usted que estudia el vínculo es
justamente de este mismo se internet que
conexión hay porque estamos viendo en
las redes sociales
perfiles que están vinculando mensajes
antes pero trump
neoconservadores pro putin y
complotistas antivacunas
hay cuentas que difundían eso y ahora
están difundiendo apoyando a
alp no apoyando la invasión en ucrania
que conexión hay entre todos estos
mensajes
bueno el apoyo a estos caballos de troya
que madrid le pen ha abordado con
relativa solvencia durante su campaña
incluso de ese modo tiene que ver con un
voto anti establishment contestatario
que desconfía profundamente y que
reniega del
orden de la democracia liberal y de la
democracia parlamentaria que no tiene
problemas en blanquear a líderes
autoritarios y nacionalistas como putin
y esto es algo que han hecho otras
formaciones de derecha no sólo dentro de
la ultraderecha aquí en francia
con juega muy bien con el discurso
antivacunas porque es un discurso que
reniega igualmente del
consenso científico y del consenso
político
esto es algo a lo que mal el epen
también apela en su campaña cuando habla
de estas libertades al final cuando
habla de libertades no son cualquier
tipo de libertades y unas libertades que
tienen que ver con saltarse el consenso
científico
en qué diferencias hay justamente
hablando del epen entre la ley penn de
2017 y la depende de 2022 dicen que ha
suavizado su discurso
bueno esto realmente se lleva diciendo
desde que marie le pen llega a la
presidencia del frente nacional en 2011
pero no hay que olvidar que el frente
nacional es un partido cuyo fin último
es el poder no es tanto su propio
programa
entonces ya se llama el epen desde que
fundara el partido en 1972 ha recurrido
a esta estrategia de moderación
intentando alejarse de los elementos más
radicales de la escena de ultraderecha e
incluso neofascista de francia
entre 2017 y 2022 sí que hay una cierta
recuperación de un discurso más liberal
en favor del nacional populismo que hubo
durante la campaña de 2017
fundamentalmente llevada por el número 2
entonces de mabel dentro de filippo que
acaba expulsado del partido pero
realmente lo que hay que pensar es que
los programas de extrema derecha son muy
permeables son muy plásticos y qué
lo que funcione en ese momento pues
normalmente se adapta sí porque antes
ella defendía salir del euro de la unión
europea hacer un referendo sobre la
migración ahora todas esas líneas rojas
lo que parecían líneas rojas las ha
abandonado completamente ya no está por
el flex y ya no está por hacer ese
referéndum sobre la inmigración incluso
ha apostado parece que se ha se haya
dado cuenta es la primera candidata que
se dio cuenta de que el poder
adquisitivo iba a estar en el centro de
esta de esta campaña electoral al
principio decíamos que el otro candidato
de extrema derecha se me estaba
desinflando en los sondeos
porque ha perdido intención de votos
porque no parecía que va a ser un duelo
entre ellos dos finalmente se ha ido
desinflando yo en el fondo pienso que el
hecho no es un político de hecho él
hasta bien entrado 2020 2021 cuando ya
tiene una trayectoria mediática
importante no empieza a dar señales de
que podría presentarse a las elecciones
de 2022 él es un tertuliano es un
periodista y en el momento en el que se
encuentra
en un debate cara a cara con otros
políticos con mucha mayor trayectoria y
no en su zona de confort que puede ser
el plato de ese news en el momento que
se encuentra frente a una gran audiencia
yo creo que es una personalidad que se
desinfla esto no quita que lo que se
encarna que es esta derecha
desacomplejada identitaria
ultracatólica
y definitivamente lo que
la parte del frente nacional que
madeleine a
moderado
esto no quita que lo que él representa
vuelva a la carga después de 2022 cuando
el éxito efectivamente no pase
seguramente al segundo a la segunda
vuelta si finalmente se confirma y pasan
mccomb y la pena segunda vuelta le pen
podría recuperar esos votos de ese modo
o no todos probablemente pero
viendo que el voto de mccoy normalmente
es el voto de las rentas altas y en
cierto modo el de ese modo en
comparación con le pen también e
igualmente viendo la soltura con la que
el gobierno de macrón ha abordado
ciertos temas relacionados con el
discurso de extrema derecha es posible
que parte del voto de hoy se mueva
efectivamente vaya para de manuel marco
no lo dudo bueno pues veremos qué pasa
el domingo muchísimas gracias a arsenio
cuenca por todo este análisis muchas
gracias
más gracias a todos ustedes por habernos
acompañado ya saben que nos pueden
seguir también por internet en rf y
mundo.com en france24 puntocom hasta
pronto amigos
[Música]
[Aplausos]